[Music]
well it happened again I saw a film that
was so horrible that it completely
knocked the senses out of me only this
time it left me in a comatose state
whenever will I learn
what do you think I'm going up I don't
know brentalfloss why would we bother
using our names with each other if we
already know each other I used to put
Dumanis to introduce as you are why we
were both in your reviews it's in case
people for God forgot it's rylynn I
don't win the volume you should share my
tries again
what do you think of we oh I don't know
you have you ever seen them the softer
critic like this well once when you
watch baby geniuses God you don't think
that get the laptop maybe geniuses to
was downloaded on Netflix damn fool dad
damn fool he's got a pal an hour we got
to wake him up yeah hey come on come on
a grill credit wake up pranks I love it
they were trying down there was no use
for I had seen that which cannot be
unseen what it had been seen by unseen
eyes I had witnessed baby geniuses too
the idea alone that the first film was
popular enough to warrant a sequel is
shocking enough but the fact that it has
an even bigger budget more effects and
the balls to actually continue a story
that nobody outside the disturb mental
ward would want to see continued is
enough to send anyone into a comatose
state god help me this isn't working
choice shock therapy oh okay critic 50
shades of grey was meant to be taken
seriously what
well that would shock me yeah I know I
just didn't know that you want to go
read it again alright here that the
memory of the film is far too painful it
all began with big shock babies except
this time around they actually got some
babies that lip-sync their lines okay in
anguish Ringelmann if your mom and dad
add some shading some of them what's
gonna make you cranky communicate both
babies and adults
this kids effects are so good they
almost rival the Super Bowl babies
Margie Sonic you aren't you a bit more
attention span yes they both are great
promotions for violence against children
sit back and let me tell you another
story but the legendary Kizuna and his
archenemy captain King the kids decide
to talk about the history of a secret
agent called Kahuna I'm scared PETA
means guru and a busting you kids daddy
you might be thinking the Disney Channel
is airing their production of
Schindler's List but this is the
backstory of Kahuna who I guess has a
history of saving children from evil
research at the Berlin Wall because yeah
most young viewers of this movie know
exactly what the Berlin Wall is and if
not isn't this a great way to learn
about it
apparently kahuna had the power to
transform into a 21 year old stunt
gymnast and knew how to rescue children
from a bizarre celebrity cameo it's
wonderful what you do here saving
orphans children I have a soft spot for
the gentle ofte of pigs
that's Jon Voight by the way I think
they got him because Christopher Walken
wasn't available
his silliness levels reach spectacular
heights of awkward I don't want this
umbrella deal off the compound plus I
hope poom
I'll work ever wonder what Captain
Kangaroo would be like as a Nazi of
course you haven't
but the director feels the need to force
this freaky reality on you anyway I want
to get one last word it's a cliche but
I'm intrigued
what is your last word Jack duck still
of
[Music]
and that technically has been jump
instead of duck oh well it's not like
the henchmen who do it anyway most of
their job consists of standing perfectly
still while a little person does wire
work and even Pinocchio were called
dated lumbus I will I will destroy you
if it take me forever yes I would
destroy your ever proportionate changing
body organs Lee's Berlin of course just
as they were talking about this guy he
appears years later at their daycare
about to promote a new television
network this is a network called kids
everywhere which I assume is a just as
equally evil spin-off of for kids is my
greatest pleasure
well now's the launch of the largest
seasons network is very clear should
somebody tell him they're no longer
holding auditions for The Carol Burnett
Show
you know why is he playing that role
Queen Latifah
yeah I always imagined Angela Lansbury
look we're getting off topic critic look
give us a sign and you can hear us no
use duties gone too far I think in a
situation like this you would have
wanted us to go through his wallet wait
wait wait look maybe he can communicate
with us critic if you can hear us blink
alright here a Jew do you know what this
calls for what's that
more sexy shades of gray alright okay
done that and that done that wanted that
I have a st. Bernard you wanna borrow
while those two horny bastards read
their Twilight porn I continue to
remember the horror of my viewing we're
introduced to this teenage girl who
looks after the babies at the daycare
and like most attractive girls at that
age she has a heck of a time getting a
boyfriend
okay hair good I know it's usually the
guy who laughs hey it's cool I was gonna
ask you anyway I felt kind of weird
asking you to termi so glad you asked me
first kidding you right and like most
attractive boys at that age he is far
more interested in her brain than her
smoking-hot body
ah when will the genders learn poor
Archie oh look the babies are trying to
be entertaining again oh how they fail I
just mean well you actually have a
question is she speak for yourself
brain by two this movies credit this is
possibly the best form of birth control
available
I mean if for any other reason not to
give these people more babies to keep
making sequels put the gem rating given
the boom disc so the bad guys disk with
all their evil plans on it of course
falls into the baby's carriage rather
than do something crazy like oh I don't
know ask the teenage girl for it back
they decide to scare the shit out of her
chasing her down and they're always
terrifying black meaty pants
but Kahuna appears and don't freak out
they do explain why he doesn't age and
we partake in him beating up the world's
prettiest henchman you know it's funny
at times the effects in this movie are
actually pretty good and then other
times they look like stop-motion hot
wheels are you what are you company if
you want to live no time for small talk
we got a buggy little ladies buggy wow
I've been saved by a baby
this is an early low in my relatively
young life he takes them to the
Hollywood sign which it turns out is
actually a secret location floor
Willy Wonka's Batcave there is no life I
know to compare with what is he much
head yeah I think by this point the girl
has most likely accepted the fact that
she's been gassed how else could she
explain scenes like this hello care to
give the only pagination station ago
nice those British accent lessons from
Dick Van Dyke really paid off
but at least there is one real person in
the cave a boy coincidentally the same
age as our nanny here how did you meet
Kahuna
we found me in a Russian orphanage I was
alone and scared my father died and no
wonder when my mom was why was he there
oh it was helping match up parents at
their lost kids he tried but could never
find my mom don't try to give a valid
performance pal we both know neither of
us are putting this on our resumes get a
load of this apparently there's a
machine that exposes every baby
superpower
Archie your hidden strength is the power
of your mind you are brain boy grating
thing : you have more strength than you
realize you are baby
courageous Rosita as tough as you are
you have a vast depth of love you are
Cupid girl Oh bullshit it's bad enough
that she's exposed to the MOT Ethan
drone but it's the girl with the useless
emotional power while the boys get all
the ones that actually do something for
that matter am I the only one that finds
it interesting that the gifts being
given in this movie our brains heart and
courage a brain ah ha ha
the no I'm not sure if that's supposed
to make the black kid Dorothy or toto
but either way I'd be insulted speaking
of the insulting use of black people mr.
Garre Oh finally
listen I went to the graduation remember
the kids we got fruit island yeah my
goodness I'd make a joke about how
phoned in this cameo is but it's
literally phoned in
she makes the appearance via camera
phone god I haven't seen a Whoopi
Goldberg call in cameos
as bad since the other Whoopi Goldberg
calling cameo she did let's be fair
though she probably had a lot more
important projects she needed to attend
to like the filming at Theodore fucking
racks actually it turns out that Kahuna
has connections that go even higher up
than the view cast members the president
online can you hold for a moment mr.
president you know I would believe at
the time that the president was giving
his advice from the toddler not too
far-fetched oh crap the critics got a
panel like two minutes I'm sad we can't
let him water around the hallways like
this what we gonna do oh that's why I
showed my balls in suburban tights and
once again I deeply apologize for it any
other questions wicket what's your
favorite review whoo that would have to
be a full-on rude review with that
fantastic brentalfloss cameo that man is
a genius you know I do remember having
much more fun directing my on your
review is that wonderful anime comedian
uncle yo that jealous Anthony who died
in a toilet
I don't know thinking more clearly about
it I think it is definitely moral rule
is retarded momentarily I remember Anya
with a pause review better video does
that answer your question no top
here's something strange believe it or
not they actually give a very detailed
backstory to the Kahuna kid apparently
he drank a formula that his father
created that made him super strong and
stop the aging process even though
clearly he aged a little from the last
time we saw him hey man
the first gives everybody the creeps
he's a freak again just like most boys
growing up they totally hate the kid
who's incredible at sports and has
unbelievable strength this movie so
captures the voice of our complex youth
like how apparently they fall in love
despite having know each other for less
than 24 hours well I've always said
relationships are more shallow the
closer you get to Hollywood hey come on
it's better than half the jokes they're
putting out but at least we do figure
out captain K gurus evil plan hold it
there that fat box
hooked up to the TV is giving enough
power to light up Times Square if this
man wants to conquer the world what
better way than television well there's
the internet water controlling food
supply air actually just about
everything would be more effective than
television in fact I think people would
actually rather watch air the television
nowadays what was your next big plan
hypnotizing people through MySpace
but during the big premiere of Kermit
the Frog in the jazz singer
Kahuna tries to stop them from airing it
to the world
it's alright this isn't cinnamon it's
okay I just murdered an innocent child I
have money and an accent so that's fine
when our heroes tried to tell them
what's really going on the scheme
there's some kind of mind-control thing
on the show yo feel bad bad bad bad
no wonder Angelina Jolie is so messed up
I had to see that through my childhood I
probably have some issues too so they
put him in a cage that he could easily
just walk out of but he uses his devices
that the henchmen left beside him to
break out heaven these morons ever watch
Batman you have to leave the utility
belt in another room come on this is
comic book logic kahuna makes it back to
the scrump-dilly-icious cave but the
villains follow
I want that disk you want it come & get
it
luckily kahuna has the ability to make
the disk fly what you miss the part
where he said he could do that so did
everybody but the babies activate their
superpower baby abilities got a
verbalizing this and they use their
special powers to defeat the henchman
heck we even see what Cupid girl does I
Love You Man so cute the girl's job is
to spread the gay all while forcing them
into giant man piles
I guess they're right being gay is not a
choice it's a small girl with a magic
arrow that forces you against your will
to make love to the same gender now
that's an interesting development I have
to say but captain crowd Aroo still
manages to get the disc and uses it to
start the countdown of hypnotizing
people I did it I did it I did it
and we also learn his true identity what
happened back then wasn't my fault you
don't have to keep the hating me for you
think I went to all this trouble just
because they'd like you best
[Music]
he was actually the older brother of
Kahuna and I'm not gonna lie that's
actually a pretty good twist and I
haven't joking I really didn't see that
coming and it makes total logical sense
I mean for baby genies is - it doesn't
make sense is this kids no and stop them
and stop them and stop them and stop
them and stop them and stop them and you
know I'm beginning to see why this lazy
bastard loses so much he never puts any
goddamn effort into it
God don't ask this guy to design any
motivational posters soon you can do it
unless you have to climb stairs in which
case you cannot so they just rewire the
programming they hypnotize people to be
nice to each other but Berlin wack here
has a plan to use the machine to turn
him into a super baby forgetting that it
would turn him into a baby cat even
Donald Duck was a better not see that
you I feel this gain and if you touch my
type watch your fire by god this film is
awful all right if this doesn't wake him
up nothing else will
game on one two but the ironic thing
about baby geniuses too is that as bad
as the film is it's still not as
horrible as the first one what oh it's
bad horrendous even but at the very
least there was an attempt to put effort
into it I mean at least there's some
imagination at least there's some
backstory atleast john-boy can get an
uncomfortable laugh based on the sole
realness of his performance which is
actually much more than I can say for
the first one it's a terrible movie but
when it comes to comparing the two this
one isn't quite as painful so wait why
would it put you in a comatose state
it didn't I just knew if I convinced the
hotel there was more than one person in
this room might get a better rate you
wasted our Saturday yeah what if three
grown men two of them from New York
going to do in a hotel room
the king-sized bed that the man I don't
know if that is holding it the wrong way
yeah oh that is nasty the classic hey
guys what are you doing
18 for start no we're just three grown
men sitting on a king-size bed reading
Fifty Shades agree you want to join them
yeah that's right
awesome come on I'll be affirming for
more ad do they never actually have sex
in this no hey you know be fun let's
read this a different voices oh yeah
Mickey Mouse yeah
wait I see across twice my fuck oh great
what wait sir my whipper he's my
attorney triumphant oh we got voices
down boys I need Rubina Cooper God who
drew me in it ah
what's this Evos the crap up so I can
see it yes sir
are you sure he was so angry at me yes
please sir you're right god I Roy's got
em I got em even planning today I shut
the room out he came out the crawl out
star small biting links from the crop
against mine barely one small moving
down off small objects against my
clitoris once twice three times you get
anything they're very hard the lady
it's Oh finally that's it I can take no
more and I come
Zucco's gather we've got our way
tomorrow and I come gloriously lovely
signing weekly pick on Karl around me of
my legs
tiny Gianni like this all been doing his
embrace my head against the ship mo and
I mewling and I'm whimpering as they
have to sharpen my orgasm conceive me
that's right yes I'll do what about
doing burger joint American why not boys
big he lifts me and suddenly we're
moving my arms still tethered above my
head
and I can feel the cool wood of the
Polish Cross of my back and he's popping
the button on his jeans he puts me down
against the cross legally he does when
he strides on a fondo and then his hands
wrap around my thighs as he lifts me
again
awesome okay family one way to end up
guys I think we need Nicolas Cage were
we
well nothing I lift your legs burger
I feel so weak haha but I do as he says
that me rocks my leg around any tire
with one thrust easier to hide me and I
cry out again listen angel was muffled
knowing this is the best party ever yeah
[Applause]
Oh
I need a break
call bathroom I call the bathroom first
Kotoko throw that time you're coming
with us for years
I fill Biscayne and if you catch my type
as you're fired